rolls-royce is the quintessential luxury
automaker it doesn't make sports cars it
doesn't sell trucks and it's cars aren't
built for utility at least until now in
a manner befitting this tradition
steeped brand rolls-royce announced
plans to build its first ever SUV via a
hand-delivered coast oh thank you very
much so why would a century-old
automaker which is famous for providing
the world's elite with an incomparably
hushed smooth ride try to recreate that
experience in a vehicle popular with
soccer moms Rose Royce is also not by
nature's fault and not utility so for
that reason if we do it we do it perfect
and we do it in a non compromised form
well maybe the news shouldn't come in
such a shock one could actually say
rolls-royce built the original sports
utility vehicle all the way back in the
1930s but Rolls Royce is real motive
isn't memories it's the moolah global
SUV sales soared eighty eight and a half
percent from 2008 to 2013 and according
to IHS SUVs will make up one of every
five vehicles sold next year
drivers love them because they can take
them anywhere that's a fact that Rolls
Royce plans to trumpet by calling its
SUV the everywhere vehicle automakers
love them because they're big margined
behemoths Rolls Royces luxury
competitors have already stepped out of
their wheelhouse to wade into the
utility waters 13 years ago Porsche
built a big four-door station wagon on
beefed up suspension now SUVs make up
the majority of Porsche sales and plenty
of its profits but rolls-royce is known
for luxury on another level so the real
question is what will good woods
gazillion-dollar gargantuan cost and
what will it look like
you